How's it going, Paul?
It's A Friday. How are you?
I'm alright.
Paul, Chris, good to see you both.
Lee, how are you?
Thank you.
Hey.
Doing well.
Kris, been a been a little bit. How have you been?
Been good, man.
Good.
Yeah, just getting back from New York.
Yeah, yeah, how was your trip?
It was great, man. It was good. I enjoyed my time.
Did you get, I was going to say, did you get any personal fun time in there?
Yeah, that's all it was, was personal.
Nice, nice. Does that, when you do, oh yeah. Oh, I was going to ask, for you with personal fun time in New York City, does that include, does that include dinners, theater, shows, anything like that? What do you guys do?
How about your tribute, huh?
Well, I didn't do any, um, any show.
Okay.
Kind of ran out of time, but we did the main attractions.
The Statue of Liberty, and then...
Nice.
Then the Empire State Building and the top of the rock and...
No, 911 Memorial.
Very nice.
There's a few other things that we did, but never really made it to one of the shows.
Yeah, it happened.
Well, I'm glad to hear you had a nice time.
Yeah, so how was yours? I know last time we talked you were you were heading out of the country. I guess they let you back in.
They did, they did, just barely there. No, so I went to China with my family and I was able to take the first week that I was there off and then last week I worked from there, which was
which was tricky because, you know, there was a lot of, it was almost the exact opposite, right? It's 12 hours, I guess that is the exact opposite of our day, 12 hours ahead. So I would be out doing things during the day and then I'd work from 9 P.m. to 5 A.m. and then I'd get like,
Mhm.
three hours of sleep and then jump out with my family and do stuff. But it was great. It was really cool.
We traveled all around, saw some things that were thousands of thousands of years old, which we don't really get in the States so much. So
Yeah.
Hey, Tim.
Hey, how you doing?
Be good.
Good to see you.
Yu.
And then I see, I see Lewis as well.
Hey, Louis.
Kip.
It's 2 minutes after Amit, are we waiting on?
Yeah, we do good to start. Aman is out of office, but we still wanted to have this connect just to quickly go through how the team is doing, check the pulse of the team, and yeah, if there is anything at all that we need to pick up for next week, we just wanted to have this touch point. So yeah, Luis, to start with self, how the week has been.
Yeah.
how the team is progressing, specifically Vernie, given that he recently started. I was talking to Janet. He's picking up slowly, but again, wanted to take your perspective, how things are moving.
I mean, nothing really to report. I mean, obviously he's new, so it's going to take a minute before he actually, you know, hits the ground running for the most part. So just giving him that opportunity to pick up everything. I mean, yeah, he obviously he replaced Dexter's time shift for the most part. And
Mhm.
Yep.
But yeah, just...
Keeping an eye, I see how things are going. So far, nothing popped out as far as like, why would you do that type scenarios or anything like that. So, so far, so good.
No, that is great, and we are ensuring that he sits next to Janad, given that you know Janad has that knowledge he can share and the KT becomes easy, so we are ensuring that you know he's working very closely with Janad while he walks through it. Another thing, Lewis, we wanted to check availability for 20th.
because that's when we will have onboarding of the new engineer, right? And we want to check that what time works for you because our onboarding manager, Rick, would be on the call just to go through the usual stuff, which is around the CDP, what successful looks like for the new engineer, so on and so forth.
So pretty much the same thing that we've done in the past, just that it will be done by the dedicated person this time. So yeah, wanted to check what time works for you guys so that I can get him to send the invite.
I responded, I think it was to Aman email when he wanted an update, but I think you just said that he's out today. So it was for 10 A.m. on Tuesday, the 21st.
Okay.
Yeah.
Aarti.
Fantastic, okay.
Works great.
All right, I think I'm good at this stage. Like I said, that I still wanted to have a quick checkpoint just to go through and see if there is anything at all that we needed to focus on. Lee, anything from you?
Just the biggest thing for me is checking in with, I mean, Lewis and Kris again, getting a chance to say hello, but also see, you know, we had a lot of talks. We've been working together for a while now as a group to make sure that we're rowing in the right direction.
The impression that I have at this point is that we are, right? Maybe not everything is 100% buttoned up and perfect, but there's been a lot of advancement, a lot of strides made on both sides, and the teams coming together to do so. I just want to make sure that that's your impression as well. Did you guys
feel good about where we are and after if there's anything outstanding that seemed like roadblocks to the relationship. Now we don't necessarily have to dig into that on this call. We can have a follow-up of it but I but if there's anything high level then that's truly operational. This would be a good
Abdul.
Outlet, I guess, to talk about those.
For me, nothing stands out at this time. I mean, obviously we have those staff changes that's pretty much, you know, continuing its way through to deal with, you know, that perspective, which is going to take a minute. It's not going to be obviously an instant thing. So I'm not looking for an instant or anything in that degree, just being patient to see how it goes.
Yeah.
And then with that, see how the new hires are doing for the most part. You know, I am just looking forward as far as a light at the end of the tunnel for the most part. So nothing negative on my end, you know, with that said. So, but yeah, yeah, I think everyone, I think as far as, you know,
Taking care of the tickets to that degree, we are seeing a lot of activity coming from ITBD. And then as we also initiated the new process as far as what we call a next step, where we're actually putting in what the next steps are into each individual ticket, which, yeah, then, you know, it goes down the path of, hey, now we have a direction to give to the next person.
Das.
but then it also actually shows a sign that the ticket was updated, you know, to that degree as well. So it's nailing a couple bases that we've been wanting to deal with for the most part. So, but yeah, things are looking forward.
That's great. That's great, Louis. Yeah, I love that for you guys. Getting that in there is great. It also allows you better capability of like filtering out where action is required, right? So not only the visibility when you're doing due diligence after the fact, but even just trying to determine a filter that can allow people to understand, oh, we should
target this or making an update to next ticket, right, to capture, oh, if it's been this duration since the last update. So if you guys haven't already done that, then I recommend updating next ticket to capture that as well. I assume you have, because you guys have been pretty on top of next ticket. Great.
Thank you, Lewis. Kris, from your perspective, anything worth adding?
No.
not related to that.
I think.
We're seeing...
some improvement, some movement of the needle, right? So it's just more of, for me, is continuing to drive those efficiencies.
Yep.
is the big thing for me.
Okay, great. And Kris, one thing I wanted to do, if we could, carve some time to kind of dig into any...
dig in and maybe sounding board or brainstorm against any of the, which of the needles are moving the slowest, right? And see if maybe my experience or our combined experiences can garner some thoughts as to what I might be able to work with Amit and Team on.
Yeah.
or whatever, the group as a whole, to see if there's anything we can do to push. So if you're willing to give me the, I don't know, a 30 minute window next week, I'd love for us to catch up in that regard. Does that work?
Mhm.
Yeah, let's look for um...
Kip.
On Wednesday, Thursday, and next week.
Make that happen. Dump it into my calendar now.
Uh, how does...
How does one, I've got a big old window between 1:00 and 3:00 on Wednesday. Any time in there work for you?
That's the 22nd.
Yeah, yep. Wednesday booked.
Yeah, I can. So I have.
I can do.
We have a 130.
Yeah, so I can do a 215.
215 to 245, something like that.
Sure, I'll drop it on.
And I'll come to the table with some thoughts, but it'll be good, even if we just like baseline some things and figure out, hey, it would be good for us to take a look at this and then I can take it back and see what we can see on our side, do some homework.
Mhm.
All right, excellent.
Thank you. Yeah, that was it from my side, right? I just wanted to, you know, Aman and I, we're working with the team. Obviously, Aman and the engineers are putting in their due diligence. We just want to make sure that we're setting ourselves up by ourselves, I mean, the full group up for success. I think a lot of these changes that we're referencing, when we're saying the staffing changes, I think these are
are good moves, right? Otherwise, we wouldn't have recommended them. Otherwise, you guys would have probably agreed. So it's fair to say that we need to give them time to bake in. But I wouldn't be surprised if we start feeling the difference from there.
relatively quickly as people ramp up.
Yeah, Amit, that was it for me. Anything, I'll kind of throw you the floor back.
Yeah, thank you. Paul, anything from you?
No.
All right.
I think we're good then. We will have the onboarding call set up. Luis, thank you for confirming the time and we can get this moving. Anything pops up in between, drop me a message. While Aman is away, I will be in contact with the team and I'll keep the team posted.
Yeah.
Right. Thank you, Kris, Paul, Lewis, Tim. Wish you a wonderful weekend ahead, and yeah, speak soon.
Thanks, y'all. Bye.
Very good, thank you.
Just a fact.
Great. Thanks, everybody. Chat with you all soon.
Take care.
Yeah.
Have a great weekend.
Bye-bye.